all right let's do another one of these
propaganda disinformation breakdowns
where we look at a claim and explain why
it is deceptive yet tricky and why it
will often convince a lot of people into
just pour unfounded conclusions Donald
Trump is under fire for his recent
Pardons and clemency grants that he
issued including to people like Bernie
Kerik the former Illinois governor Rod
Blagojevich and others and Donald Trump
jr. the president's son recently tweeted
quote Dems are mad at Trump for abusing
his pardon power total presidential to
presidential pardons sentence
commutations and then it lists Jimmy
Carter had 566 and Reagan had 406 you
know says Obama had 1927 and that Trump
has only done 26 Pardons and
commutations and Donald Trump jr. goes
on to say please by all means educate me
on abuse of power so you look at this
and many trumpets have and they
retweeted and they love it and they say
look look look there can't be anything
wrong with Trump's pardons because he's
done 26 and all these other presidents
did way more that's where you have to
say wait wait a second here let's apply
some critical thinking first of all
let's take on the quantity argument
Donald Trump has only pardoned 26 people
right now he's only in the middle of his
first term presidents tend to issue
pardons not just at the end of their
terms but at the end of their
presidencies so when you look at totals
many presidents got the vast majority of
their pardons and kremens clemency
grants in at the very end of their
respective presidencies and until we see
what Donald Trump does in his last days
or his last hours at the Oval Office the
comparison is not relevant number two
some of these numbers are very deceptive
so Barack Obama the number is 1927
- Donald Trump's 26 well in reality
Barack Obama pardoned 212 people and
then he commuted about 1,700 sentences
when you look at those commutations that
Barack Obama did a ton of them
our drug offenders that Donald Trump has
also previously said shouldn't be in
prison and that he wants to go ahead and
deal with on in July of 2015
Obama commuted 46 drug sentences in June
of 2016
Obama did another 42 drug sentence
commutations in December of 2016 during
the Trump transition period another 80
roughly a few days before leaving office
another 64 on his last day in office
another 330 so not only can you not look
at these numbers until a presidency is
over number one the vast majority of the
commutations from Barack Obama which Don
jr. is apparently complaining about are
very similar to when Donald Trump
himself pardoned Alice Johnson after Kim
Kardashian lobbied him to do it Alice
Johnson had spent 21 years behind bars
for a nonviolent drug offense if
pardoning people for nonviolent drug
offense sentences is good according to
Trump Don jr. can't also say Obama's bad
for doing the exact same thing Trump
here is pardoning corrupt criminals
Trump is laying the groundwork to pardon
more of his own cronies Trump is
normalizing corruption and setting
himself up to pardon Roger stone and or
Michael Flynn and whoever else Obama had
nothing to gain personally by commuting
the sentences of drug offenders when he
was on his way out of office other than
fighting the failed war on drugs in some
small way Trump has plenty to gain by
normalizing corruption when he's
planning to use that pardon power
presumably
to get his own friends and cronies out
of prison so do not fall for these bogus
arguments that sound good Don jr. does
them on Twitter a lot there's a guy
whose name is Charlie Kirk who's part of
a right-wing mostly like college
centered group called Turning Point USA
you see these tweets and because they
are so crafted to appear to be something
they are not
it looks like Wow checkmate liberals
weary we can't even argue with that
Obama 1900 and Trump only 26
you've got a look at the details you
have to understand what's not being said
you have to understand the hypocrisy and
the double standards and the reality of
these things to actually understand them
and you've got to give them credit they
are really good at bamboozling a lot of
the people that support Donald Trump
part of it is their bamboozle able
people a part of it is they are actually
pretty good at it and we've got to do
what we can to try to pierce the echo
chamber I want to give a quick shout out
to one of our sponsors VIN Charo watches
they're giving my audience 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch maybe you don't
usually wear a watch and you've been
thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have check out vin chair oh it's an
american company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look amazing and they
look like something you'd spend a lot of
money on but ever even chero watch
ranges from a hundred and fifty to three
hundred dollars I went on their website
and picked out the Kyros in white and
silver really loved the look the
combination of the white face and the
beige band really loved this one they
also sent me the Kairos limited release
gold reserve set totally different style
this one would make a fantastic gift for
a couple people I can think of in my
family anytime you see me wearing a
watch on the show I'm wearing a Ventura
watch go through their collection I know
you'll find something you like and
you'll get 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch